now i'm gonna need some clarity
on what you told me you said that you
like picking blackberries off the side
of the road
i really would like to get some clarity
on that
but i guess i'll have to save that for
another time
uh so everyone please welcome jacqueline
[Music]
um so just for the fact uh blackberries
grow on bushes all over roads here in
the seattle area and
um yeah one of my favorite hobbies is
just walk off the side of the road and
grabbing the blackberry so they're not
off the ground they're not from
people selling them they're somewhere in
between the two so hi
i'm jacqueline dolis my twitter handle
is at sky tetra and this is about my
website tweet mashup and r
and what i learned from porting my viral
website from.net to shiny
so part one what is tweet mashup
so before i even get into that don't go
to tweetmashup.com yet you're gonna be
inclined to
doing this whole presentation go to
tweetmashup.com but don't go
there are spoilers there and we don't
want spoilers you want the max intrigue
of this presentation
so don't go there yet so tweet mashup
was a website i made
that let you take two different twitter
accounts and take tweets from them and
mash them up into a new funny tweet
you could select from like pre uh six
pre-selected pairs
to tweet uh mashup or you could make
your own pairs of accounts
um so you could put in twitter accounts
it would generate funny tweets like the
thing at the bottom
um and so people had fun with this on
the internet it took me like a year to
develop the website and then i launched
it and people were doing funny things
like it
like here's one i'm not gonna read these
tweets out loud because um
it's funnier if you just read them but
i'm gonna give you a second to take in
that joke
um here's another good joke
i think that tweet mashup generated um
and here is um a little bit more about
it
so the website was launched in 2016.
it went viral within like three days and
it to the point where at one point had
three thousand people concurrently
viewing the website um
we're all like putting it under a load
at the same time and so because of that
it crashed a lot at first um i had no
idea people are gonna like this website
so much
and so i didn't think about how it
handled that scale and then eventually
after a couple weeks it stopped being so
popular but during that like
viral bump i actually got like mentioned
on the verge that article on the left is
me being mentioned on the verge website
um and then on the right that's john
ledger who has like three or four
million followers tweeting about my
website
um so we've got a lot of traffic that i
wasn't expecting
um but here's the secret
here's the secret i didn't make it an r
i actually programmed it in my favorite
programming language f sharp
and now you're like oh jacqueline nolis
you're presenting at it our conference
you presented at r studio conf you seem
so much like an r person but
actually f sharp's my favorite language
um and f sharp is
it's basically it's a functional
programming language so if you know the
r package per
which is fantastic f sharp is basically
a whole programming language
that's based on um that philosophy of
using um
maps and rocks and things like that and
net
is the framework that contains f sharp
it's for most like
modern windows development uses.net or
if you ever heard of c sharp which is
like one of the most popular programming
languages in the world
that's.net and f sharp is the functional
equivalent and so
it's a very mature platform which means
it's very good at handling things like
scale and creating websites
um but like i said it wasn't ready to
scale i launched it on sunday
on a sunday night i shared it with my
friends and i like you know i'm like for
fun i'm gonna spend 10 bucks on twitter
ads
but my friend started tweeting about it
which somehow got it to the supernatural
fandom starting to tweet about it we
started getting to the anime fandom
and then 4chan and then alt-right and
this all happened over the course of
like three hours and then suddenly
boom everyone was tweeting about this
website um and so here on the left you
can see immediately it started crashing
tweet mashup more like tweet crash up
you know that's me getting burned
um so i had some unrealistic assumptions
also by the way this
talk is filled with jokes and normally
when i give talks people laugh at the
jokes but there's no one here but me
so i'm assuming everyone's laughing when
i'm saying these things that it's very
funny
so anyway so i had some unrealistic
assumptions
um i assumed i didn't have to worry
about twitter api limits glenn i think
i'd have that much scale
i assumed that memory wouldn't be an
issue that money
of the the server sides that on wouldn't
be an issue and that would only be used
by people in the us
um so if you look on the left this is a
tweet from brazil that got
4 000 retweets i don't get the joke i
don't speak portuguese
but um i'd even consider that when i was
thinking about how the mashups were made
so a lot of things i wasn't ready for
but i learned that memes fall hard so
like i said it launched on that sunday
it peaked on that wednesday there's one
hour one hour where i had about 20 000
views
and then forever after that declined and
so it went from that 200
000 a single day with 200 000 sessions
to eventually down to about 1 000
sessions a day for like years after that
so i went
pretty quickly you know even after two
weeks is already pretty quickly just
about done
but eventually i decided to pull the web
plug on the website because what would
happen
was about every three months twitter
would change around how the
authentication works for the twitter api
which meant that the c-sharp library
that handled twitter changed which meant
my code had to change
not to go in and edit around f sharp
code and this is annoying because every
three months i'd get
emails and things like that saying hey
the site is down can you fix it hey hey
and it felt like a big emotional burden
and this is already after the huge
emotional burden of it crashing a lot in
the first place and like i just had a
lot of too much emotions tied up on this
website
so i finally after a couple years said
you know what i'm pulling the plug
no more maintaining f sharp code for me
and so if you went to tweetmashup.com
you would see this sorry we can't reach
the webpage
um site and to the point that someone
actually even just recreated the site i
made
um with their own version called twit
combined it's not tweet mashup it's twit
combined
and here it's the exact same website but
they just put ads on it and they
remade it themselves um which is fine as
long as people on the internet had some
way of doing this mashup
uh i kind of moved on with my life for a
little bit and yeah like i said there's
just a ton of emotion tied up into
trying to keep this website alive and
all like you know all the
tweet crash of burns and stuff is just
like it was too much for me
which brings me to part two porting this
tweet mashup to shiny
i had this idea one day what if i tried
taking that tweet mashup site and i
remade it
and instead of being in dot net i did it
in shiny now this
in theory would solve my problem of when
the website going down
not having not being annoyed having to
go in and fix it because i'm like well
if it's in shiny and r i know these
tools so much better than f sharp
because i don't really use f sharp
anymore so it's gonna be a lot more
enjoyable experience to fix it
um you know shiny is just much more
continuously maintained there's a much
bigger art community
it feels like a and it'd just be fun to
see if it's even possible to take this
website i made it.net that had this big
scale
things that that went viral if i could
even make it in shiny is it even
possible
i think it'd be a fun test so i one day
i said you know what i'm gonna try doing
it let's see if i can
make this in shiny and you know this is
an r conference so
i'm glad we got to the r part so here
are the goals
i want to do five things when i
recreated the site besides just make it
work
one i wanted to ensure that the full
functionality of.net was there so
i needed to be able to like pull in
tweets mash them up
show them a website can i just do the
core basic things i need
two i wanted to be visually similar to
net so any visual things i could do
net i wanted to be able to see in shiny
as well
um three i wanted the ui to be as
snappiest.net so if
it works in shiny but every time you try
and make a mashup it like takes
you know takes a couple seconds like
that's a that's a miss
four i wanted it to handle the same load
as dot net
so ideally it should be able to handle
3000 concurrent users i mean i don't
know if we get there again ever again
but it should be able to do that in
theory if i wanted
and five it should be able to deploy as
easily as net so
um i should be able to take it from
running on my computer to running
somewhere in the cloud pretty easily
okay so again don't go to
tweetmashup.com don't go yet
please spoilers but i want to show you
that it does exist
so um you guys are all still there great
so here we go
so this is the local version and here's
tweet mashup and this is all in shiny
so here's guy tetra match up with cnn
and i can hit go
um this is all live ammunition i'm
firing i haven't pre-selected these
tweet masters in advance i don't know if
they're funny or advanced uh offensive
but um
you can see here every time i click this
shiny app it actually creates a new
meshed up tweet between me and cnn so in
theory yes
this does work um so
a little bit of us you know spoiler but
like i did recreate the site in shiny
which is pretty cool
but what did i learn along the way
um so first off
number one does it have that
functionality of.net so first off yes
the tweet matching logic of i need to
take two twitter accounts pull their
tweets together and put them into one
tweet
absolutely easy to do an r um there's
really just
one package that you need to do this
which is the r tweet package um
primarily from michael kearney
and what this package does is it does
all sorts of twitter api things for you
so like pulling the tweets in from users
mashing the tweet you know pulling the
tweets in from users and then i just use
string manipulation you know basically
stringer stuff
to just turn those sets of tweets into
one new tweet
um so actually getting the tweet mashing
logic was pretty easy
the twitter authentication was a little
trickier so
actually so if you look here we're gonna
go back to the site for a second
and so this is the one running locally
on my computer so i'm gonna go from a
new private browser so if i go from a
private browser
and i go to tweet mashup if you'll
notice i don't have the ability to type
in tweets right away
what i have to do first i have to
authorize the app and i have to do this
for twitter api reasons otherwise
my app will get cut off from twitter
which is what happened the first week i
launched it and i have to switch this
version so anyway
so if you want to actually match up a
tweet the first thing you need to do is
hit authorize
what that does is that will pass you to
twitter so if you see the url is
actually twitter.com
we put in your username and email and
then when you hit authorize app then
it'll bring you back to this version
where you actually can
type in stuff and that's really
important for tweet mashup to work
and it turns out the functionality was
not there in shiny to do this
and r to do this there's no package to
do it but it's easy for me to code it
myself
so basically all i had to do to make
that flow work if you click authorize
you go to tweet master or to twitter and
then come back to shiny
i had to just reverse engineer a little
bit of the r tweet app uh
package um to get that twitter part
working and then
you wanna store in the browser um you
wanna store that the person's logged in
so like if you refresh the page you
don't have to go through that whole
process again
so use the package called shinyjs to
keep track of the cookies
um using javascript i don't even have to
use any javascript i just copied and
pasted from the internet but
basically the point is i was able to
with a little bit of you know work on my
part get this flow working
and if you want to get the flow working
you too can use um
the code i wrote by if you go to the um
this link at the bottom i wrote a whole
blog post on how to get this working
so it's a good time
another great thing i found in shiny was
actually storing data
so if you think about it for this app to
work i want to be able to store
you know every time i want to match up
two sets of users tweets i don't want to
have to go back to twitter and ask for
all those users tweets again right
because people don't tweet very often so
i really want to cache that data i
really want to store it in memory so
every time i do a new mashup
i can just pull from the data i already
got from the twitter api and i don't
have to pull it again
but it's important that one this data
doesn't take over the entire hard drive
if i have 3 000
people using this concurrently i can't
just have my all my memory taken up so i
need to have some hard limit on
hey don't use more than n megabytes of
memory when you're storing this data
also i want to keep it fresh because
after like a day of the data being
pulled i want you to go like you know if
you pull the stuff for the my sky tetra
account
after a day i want you to go pull it
again and just in case i did make a new
tweet
and in which case um you know i want to
refresh the data
so i need this some sort of max age
where if the data is older than a
certain amount of time then just throw
it away and pull the new stuff
and so i needed that both for storing
tweets that people have made
and i also need it for storing user
credentials and so shiny's memory cache
is just like the perfect
solution for me um you just use shiny
memory cache you pass the max size so
like i want 256 megabytes of memory
uh i want to discard after a certain
number of seconds in this case one day
and if the data is missing return no
which will
let me know that if the data is not
stored in my cache i need to go pull it
again and then save it in the cache
and i was just very pleased with this
functionality because this is something
that's really important to making like a
mature
production ready app and it was just
right built into shiny and i had no idea
so that's a fun lesson
two i wanted to be visually similar to
net
um so first off it really needs to have
a customizable color palette and i put
like
flying stars to shiny here uh in
particular our studio has a new package
called bootstrap lib
and it's on github and it is an absolute
delight so if you've ever wanted to make
your shiny apps look styled
beyond the boring gray and blue that
comes default and shiny
um this package is really just fantastic
um because with a few function calls you
just you can style your app
and get like all the colors and fonts
and things like that the way you like it
so for instance
i use this bootstrap theme add variables
and i set the primary and secondary
color to the sea foam green
and then suddenly that seafoam green is
throughout my website i know if you saw
but the like
go button the banner the links they're
all that color correctly and so
just by like one function call at the
start of your shiny code you now have
things colors the way you like it
um i learned about this at an r studio
comp by uh joe
chang our studio conf tank talk this
year by joe chang it was just fantastic
and it's a really good um
primer on why this stuff is interesting
and matters and can really help so if
you if you want to make your shiny app
look pretty
and you want to do more than just like a
basic theme but you don't want to have
to go and edit css and like weird files
like that yourself
this package is simply fantastic but
for this app i actually did need to do
some custom css as well so for instance
if you look at that center
mashup thing i need css to make these
circles with our pictures
and i need css to make these thing right
aligned and these left aligned and this
you know that sort of like
that sort of stuff is all custom css so
this is actually really easy because i
had a css file that i made for my
original tweet mashup and i literally
just copied and pasted it into my shiny
app
and it worked so then when i was editing
my shiny code like in my ui for instance
if i had like a div i would just use the
the class
from my css file in the shiny app and it
totally worked
um so you know if you're not comfortable
with familiar with css yet i get that it
can be pretty intimidating also i keep
looking down because i keep checking
my time and my phone locks and that's a
problem but i still care about you i'm
paying attention
uh i'm not texting during my own talk
that would be weird
um so if you're not comfortable with
this stuff i get it it can be pretty
intimidating but i don't think it is
really that hard to get
stuff working so i highly recommend you
just try it to see how it goes
but first then we come to our first real
mess and is it as snappy as dot net
um and for some reason if you hit go on
this app and
these people aren't already in my cache
to try and
get the tweets from i have to go to
twitter api and pull it it could take 20
or 20 seconds for the poll to happen and
this is maybe like
maybe on um on net it would be in like
one or two seconds and so this is like
it's a real buzzkill because what
happened is
you hit go and just nothing would be on
the screen so if you're a user who's not
used to tweet mashup you'd have no idea
what's happening and you think the
site's broken
um i'm not sure if there's really a way
to speed up this twitter
pull without understanding more of how
our tweet works in the inner workings
and that was a level of digging into
someone else's package i'm like i don't
really want to do this
um so that was kind of a bummer um and
maybe there's some optimizations i
didn't know about that i could have made
but i just i couldn't get this that
snappy and i was disappointed by that
um and then another thing i'm like well
i can't make it snappy
at least maybe i can have some sort of
loading screen to let people know that
hey
this is loading in new tweets from the
twitter api and so i looked into this
um shiny css loaders package which puts
like here's like a little gif
showing you what the um like a loading
ui would happen while the part of the ui
is loading and shiny
and at first i'm like oh this is perfect
because it just shows you that as we're
waiting for the shiny
the twitter mashup results or sorry the
twitter api pull to get the new data in
that hey this is going to be um taking a
second but the issue was i really didn't
have that much control over it because i
wanted to show that that loading screen
when you're doing the 10 second pull
but i didn't want to show that loading
that loading animation just flash for a
second while we're waiting for the new
you know every time it once it's pulled
every time you then generate more i
didn't want to show there
and i couldn't really get that to work
so i couldn't if i had these super nitty
gritty like oh i want the animation here
but not this time things like that then
shiny kind of fell apart
um compared to net and i think um
you know maybe there's a way again to do
this in shiny and i just don't know it
yeah it's entirely possible i'm the
limitation here but it just
it seemed like a lot of work that was
more effort than it's worth and this is
something that was a lot easier in
net so again kind of felt like a little
bit of a miss on chinese side
but here's the big miss which is that
there's no way
shiny can handle the loaded.net um so i
don't know if you know how much
you the audience know how much that
shiny actually
handles concurrency but the way shiny
works is that there's only
one session of r running when shiny is
running so that means if one person is
asking shiny to go
use the twitter api to pull a new user's
information
then that 10 second block not only are
they blocked but literally
any other user of the site is also
blocked
um so that's a real problem if it takes
some seconds i can't have every
you know all these chunks of 10 seconds
where my entire site goes down for
everyone else
now there are a couple solutions for
this one you can use shiny server pro
which does allow you to have multiple r
threads at once
but it's very not free we're talking
about thousands of dollars
another thing you could do is use
kubernetes to do load balancing and have
like
20 shiny server free running and you
just balance people on that but
that's also not very free to have 20
docker containers or whatever running at
the same time
and then lastly there's a newer tool
called shiny async which lets you
actually have a separate like version of
our call to do like a long running task
so it doesn't block your
shiny but i haven't really learned how
to use it yet it seems kind of confusing
and i just like
i've already put so much time into this
project i don't want to learn that and
so
i mean but even if it gets that gets
working i i'm really struggling to see a
universe where shiny could handle 3 000
concurrent users
like f sharp did two days after my site
went viral so
uh i mean i mean i'm not trying to dig
the product our studio here but if
you're looking at having that level of
um
traffic on your site you're not gonna be
able to do it for free
in shiny and the way you could do it for
free in um.net
so that's kind of a that felt like a
mess
but a not miss was deploying it um so
deploying it went really well so what i
did was you know over the last
year several years i've been learning a
lot about how you put r into docker
containers
me and heather noel's have been working
on this if you go to put r.pro.com you
can see us talk a lot about this and
there's a lot of stuff in there about
putting plumber apis into
docker containers which is great and
important but it turns out putting a
shiny app in a docker container also is
pretty straightforward
and important and so what i did was i
took my shiny app i put it into a docker
container
and then i had that docker container
running shiny server with a single app
and i took that docker container and i
put it into google cloud
which was that google cloud was so easy
to get this working because you just
spool up a virtual
machine that's running one docker
container
um and then you um it just works and
it's deploying and it's nice and it's
easy
and then you can very easily update the
code if you want to you know push newer
versions and it was far easier than what
i was doing to deploy.net
and so i was just very happy how well
shiny played with docker and modern um
the modern um deployment ecosystem um
that said i have like a star on mostly
breeze i lost a straight week
of doing this because shiny has a weird
way of handling environmental variables
which are really important to passing
like secret credentials for the um
the twitter authentication and shiny
server like can't handle
environmental variables which is a real
problem for docker containers and if you
google
shiny server environmental variables you
find a post from joe chang in 2015
saying this is not possible in
uh shiny today and five years five years
later it's still not possible without
like a really yucky gross workaround
and i felt like this is a miss i feel
like shiny was a little bit more mature
of a platform
uh this would not have been a problem
but besides that overall i think uh
deploying to docker was was nice
um with docker google cloud was very
nice i was very happy real win on
chinese part
so the results i would say that first
off the full functionality of.net
in uh in shiny absolutely there you can
pull tweets you can mash them
you can show them in the ui really great
creating the visualizations was even
better than
net i really was happy with how easy it
was to make a beautiful website with
shiny
in a way that is not true about net
um the ui was less snappy than dot net
and that was kind of worse and it's
not easy ways to try and make it
snappier which is a problem
but the real myth was getting it to
handle load especially if you want to
make a simple
app that's free you're not going to
really be able to have it handle load in
the way that um
other platforms can and that's that's a
bummer and i mean that's not really what
shiny was designed for i get it but like
it's a bummer but it is really nice to
deploy this stuff and even if you don't
deploy like i did with google cloud and
docker you could still use shiny apps i
o
r studio connect there's a lot of ways
to deploy shiny um and i think that's
great so
here's my hot take so i think shiny is a
reasonable replacement for for
a mature.net platform like that you know
it's a it's a pretty good thing
unless you have to do stuff with load
then maybe maybe consider not using
shiny as your tool
um okay so this is gonna be and i can't
see all your faces but we're gonna we're
gonna have a fun
joint exercise so let's all right now if
you're watching this go on your phones
go whatever
we're gonna go to tweetmashup.com and
i'm really curious if we get the load of
100 people
all using this app at once and i can see
i can go to the analytics i can see okay
there are 15 of us all on the site so
let's all just start mashing up people
so i'm going to keep doing
scotch and cnn does it work okay see
look i hit go and already
it's stalling it's waiting um so
probably someone else is pulling in
a new person so as you can see the site
when i showed it to you on the um
and i showed it to you on the local
version it was running fine but here on
the um
on the real live version it's not
working so well so just to prove your
point
um but there's one last slide so this is
gonna be my
my last slide of my talk but there's one
last um
there's one last thing that happened
this happened so as i said i'm
presenting at seven in the morning
um the last thing that's happened um i'm
in a hell of my own design
so this morning i'm already getting
people messaging me saying that my
um my site is down it turns out a
hundred people i launched this yesterday
and already people are using it again
like and which causing it to break and
causing people messaging me so the
problem i had with f sharp of people are
annoyed when it doesn't work is already
biting me
when we're back and shiny and so no
platform can escape from weird twitter
authentication errors causing things to
crash and causing people to bug me so
i guess technology is never the true
solution so thank you so much
i'm jacqueline nolis that's my twitter
and um
emily robinson told me she'd be mad if i
didn't advertise her book so i put a
banner ad for the book uh emily and i
wrote at the top of my sites well thank
you
and actually stay here if i'm too late
alright well because i'm about to
advertise your book
um because we are doing giveaways we
have a bunch of your books to give away
so